Jesse Williams doesn't seem fazed by a  petition to get him fired from Grey's  Anatomy on Tuesday the 34 year old  actors co-star Ellen Pompeo shared these  new pics vacationing with Jesse in Maui  she captioned one pic when you vacation  with Jesse Williams and he's afraid to  lose you in a paddleboard race the  co-star quality time comes after jesse  was accused of being racist  following his stirring speech at the  Beatty Awards a petition was started on  change.org demanding that he be fired  from the long-running ABC show as of  Tuesday afternoon there was nearly  10,000 signatures stating that he quote  spewed a racist hate speech against law  enforcement and white people jesse has  yet to respond to the petition but he  did post this cryptic tweet on Sunday do  not promote empty people and their  tantrums